we're rounding off simple harmonic
motion but I realize that there was a
particular kind of questions actually
quite simple which I'd skipped over and
we're very easy for me to demonstrate to
you but it would be remiss of me to not
actually show you an example okay it's
where you get the characteristics of
simple harmonic motion and all the
different equations right which we used
to calling this but you get it for a
situation which is not about things that
are moving at all okay
so here's the example I'm going to give
you like like the questions that I I
really like it's a very simple setup
with very little information but you can
ask them very profound things about it
okay but we won't spend too long that
there's a um a challenge and in a
particular time of the year its
temperature fluctuates between 13
degrees and 23 degrees
the coldest time is 4:00 in the morning
and apparently in the hottest time is
4:00 in the afternoon okay so the
question is if the temperature exhibits
simple harmonic behavior it's clearly
not motion there's nothing moving here
the simple question is well we want to
know when the when the temperature is
certain numbers so they're kind of
numbers I'm after are number one when is
it 18 degrees Celsius and when is it 15
that's all that's all I want to know
okay
so how do we begin this I'm gonna give
you 30 seconds just to make a start on
that where would you pick you up your
starting point that's all you've got
that's all the information and the fact
that it's sitting on one of you and
that's all of the questions so where
would you begin I'll give you some time
to see if you can it's not and then come
together and compare
why did you begin it's a very simple
setup there's very little information so
we have to introduce some things right
come on take both of these because I
don't know which room you'd which room
you it okay okay thank you what was the
first thing you wrote down after the
question so I said yeah I heard a few
different meats but they're all no more
clear anyone
no seriously this is an important
question what is the first thing what's
an appropriate place and orderly place
to start off your approach to this
question extremities okay you wrote down
this word and what did you do with it
what does it mean
highest lowest or farthest in any
direction right well these are your
extremities here 13 degrees in 23
degrees it fluctuates between those okay
now what okay I I would like to graph it
I mean I did ask you to draw a set of
axes before we started right but before
you do that you need to I mean we don't
have an equation I've gone nothing like
what do i what am i graphing if I ever
and I've got a horizontal axis right
what did you call your vertical axis
capital T for temperature okay which
means I suppose these would be capital T
capital T capital T double dot if they
were relevant to the situation okay to
graph this thing I want to you know
write that's where I'm going to head now
you've got a couple of choices right
because you've got these points in time
right you can define for yourself where
you want this T equal 0 value to be what
are a couple of choices that would both
make sense in this context
anyone what T equals zero did someone's
not with let's say Davin what did you
choose this TV quiz here T equals zero
at that point there well that's fine I
should say okay I'm confused wrong
that's that this is a this is an open
piping question you really can set
anything you like
depending on what phase you want to know
it did anyone else having something more
concrete where did you actually think in
Savina why did you stop so you called
zero at time zero
you call that for a.m. yeah who else did
that I'm cute yeah hands up straight
okay a very small number that's
interesting
where else did the rest of you guys put
zero what did you define it to be
well did you I haven't defined it yet
that's oh I have to convert my hand out
okay the other alternative that I could
think of that might make sense is you
might call zero at midnight you could do
that I think that would be fun umm I'm
going to put it as for him I think
that's a good choice the reason why is
if I chose it as midnight right what is
the temperature at midnight and the
answer is out to her nose yet right like
I don't have an equation yet you'd have
to work that out later
whereas if I call it 4:00 a.m.
if I call it for him I know what the
temperature is then it's well defined
for me 13 degrees let's put that in
there I can't make go right now this
will lead to a problem later on namely
that when we saw the values of T they're
not gonna give us the time when you've
got T equals 10 it's not gonna be 10
a.m. it'll be well in this case if I've
said T equals 10 and we're going in
hours what time would that really be
that would be 4 a.m. plus 10 hours right
so now be sure in the afternoon so we'll
have to watch for that that's kind of a
trade-off right sometimes it's better go
to your layer to make T equals 0 some
nice value so you don't have to worry
about shift
that kind of thing but right now I don't
know what to tell you so I'm gonna stick
with that okay great
what else can I put on to you this is
the lowest temperature right so it's
gonna go up from here it's going to come
up and because it's simple harmonic it's
gonna come back down nice okay so now I
have some points on here this point over
here what time would that correspond to
that'd be for AM began what T value
would that be that'd be 24 wouldn't it
24 which is 4 a.m. again okay in exactly
the same way I've got that stationary
point up there
what T value would that be I'd be 12
winner and that corresponds to 4 p.m.
now what I'm doing here I literally do
this if it was an exponential growth
indicate situation I would often have my
T value but then I have the e that
corresponds to underneath right you want
to do everything you can to help you
understand what are these numbers and
what do they signify because people
check themselves up alert okay all right
I'm almost there
what else oh my god here up at 12 I
actually know what this value is right
so that corresponds yeah 23 degrees okay
a simple harmonic right so there's
actually another piece of information
that's implied on to this apart from the
points that I've got there what's
missing Syrian yeah the the center of
motion the middle of the graph right
it's not really a sin of omission cuz up
including but you get the same idea it's
going to be halfway in between your
extremities right which in this case
would be 18 degrees Celsius right five
degrees up and down so here we go
and then they're looking pretty sweet
okay so I have a graph now and that's
all I need so this is this is defined
for not 224 okay so can we've got an
equation off of this we build an
equation off of this it starts at an
extremity right it starts an extremity
so which of the curves are you likely to
choose for this kind of graph you know
because good okay so I have that piece
in place right which extremity does it
start at it starts at the Lord surely
then well it's not negative but it's the
it's the bottom one right so that's
going to be the sign out the front
should be negative right okay cuz it's
an upside-down cos curve what all right
what else is missing
I'm missing three numbers here I'm
missing one two three okay
there's a team there isn't it okay so
what are these three numbers at what do
they signify they're all there you tell
me which one you want to do first
amplitude okay a for amplitude when you
look at this graph what do you read the
amplitude to be it's 5 it's it's how far
you go up and down from your centre of
motion good so which number is that out
of three that's the coefficient of cause
isn't it okay good that's set
what next which one you attack after
that your dad
let's do n that's this number in the
brackets okay what's that going to
correspond to and and gives you the
period doesn't it right the period is
two ply on and whatever that n is right
well what is the period it's 24 hours
yeah okay so you can switch these guys
around and cancel I'm getting into B
Pilon twelve all right see what I did
okay one last number what's it about
what does it represent it represents the
vertical shift right again if you like
the centre of motion okay so the centre
of motion we already decided was up here
at 18 degrees Celsius right so then this
number should be 18 because if you
didn't put a number there the centre of
motion would be the origin cool we're
done okay are we ready to tackle this
question we've got equations right I
think I think we're good to go so we
want to know when these certain
temperatures are okay so I can say it's
gonna be 80 degrees when this which is
temperature is equal to 18 that
shouldn't be too hard right don't forget
there's a domain restriction on this
okay let's solve it shall we first step
don't stare at me like you can do this
first step okay good so you're gonna get
this
okay which is nice and simple don't need
to worry about that okay so this is what
I've got now you should be able to see
this in your head right is there's my
clothes graph and it usually ends at 2
pi right I'm forgetting about the fact
that this is restriction
oh sorry Pete it's been compressed right
um if I'm on tier where are these others
you know what these values are right two
values what are they cloud 2 + 3 / -
good
ok now you didn't have to graph this on
this like me sometimes you're like am I
getting the right values you just put it
there it doesn't have to be really ugly
graph so long as you're in the right
ballpark right so now I have this ok
sad all right so I wanted to do is
divide everything by piles well when you
divide this by PI + 12 that looks like 6
and we need to buy this that sounds like
18 go good so there are T values right
where would they fit that would be yeah
seems and 18th but of course this has
nothing to do with lowercase T or
uppercase T or anything like that we
want a time natural time right so then
you would say well I should say actually
I like what does that equal to well from
0 X 4 a.m. so plus 6 hours is today and
of course that's 12 hours later so 10
p.m.
cool Elessar hot all right
you'd have a go Abby it's a little
trickier because the numbers a bit more
awkward but how'd it go and see if you
get the right answer if you do call me
Aaron I'll have a look all right sorry I
didn't mean that to get your tangent I'm
actually literally clear we're through
so how did you go now let's let's
compare notes this is what you had to do
it's not enough just like the previous
question writes feel like okay sold for
15 you take it over the negatives cancel
and so you go close in verse 3/5 you get
our decimal but of course if you just
because inverse of three fits because of
the domain of cos inverse you are
between negative one and one but you
actually want to be between 0 and 24 so
you divide by 5 12 and out of these two
decimals okay now this is where most of
our problems have crept in okay so
here's what I've gotten a pet quest
attention right there's the actual
decimal okay now the first problem that
you might get is that you think oh cool
five for 54 minutes oh whoops those
aren't minutes that's decimal right so
that's your first problem that's easy to
fix because all you do is you hit this
guy which is degrees minutes seconds
okay degrees minutes
how did you do it okay now let's read
this together okay now don't forget
that's a t-value that's a t-value right
but I'm really interested in an action
time so I should have thought of this
shouldn't I since I started it for you
so what does this mean it means 7:30 -
right and then 31 now what happens after
minutes seconds how many seconds are
there in a minute there are 60 there are
60 so 31 round up um so this is really
733 a.m. okay if you went to the nearest
minute anyway and by the way HSC
questions love to do this kind of thing
because it's so easy to life anyone of
course rounds down whoops okay
now that's that's one half the answer
okay then you have to get the other end
okay how did you do that wait that 24
business come from it came things sorry
what that 20 is okay for 24 - 24 - and
if you were savvy you would have used
your um your variable notation in there
and just put it in so you just go 24
minutes that and that's where this
number comes from
okay but just like before to get from
here to an actual time yeah for okay now
those of you who struggle a little bit
with reading 24 hour time you know this
becomes 24 point four six you like what
is that that's like a that's that's zero
so what's that that's like you know
something right so I saw so here is the
okay I saw people say well okay you got
lucky 28 it actually does round town
because it's under 30 seconds right
so you wrote down 12:27 okay but then
you're like well that's am I guess this
is later right
yeah except it's not p.m. right where
would this be on this graph this would
be hearing her all the way and then
just a little bit but where is this this
is just after 4:00 a.m. because I can
read it because I wrote it right so this
is actually not 4 p.m. which would be 12
p.m. which would be over here it's
actually going to be in the middle of
the night okay
which makes sense 16 no there's nothing
a hold a minute so you're back to being
in dark times okay so there you go
simple places lots of little traps to
fall into be careful okay